HI WELCOME BACK TO THE MEETING
OF THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
COMMITTEE HELD A MEETING OF
JUNE THE EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AT THIS POINT WE DO HAVE
ENOUGH MEMBERS TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM MADAM SECRETARY COULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
Q.
HERE SHE'LL HERE AIRTEL AIRTEL
HERE GABRIEL KALRA KILEY
KEVIN KILEY HERE MAIENSCHEIN
QUIKSILVER HERE QUICK SILVER
HAIR WICKS LOOKS HERE AS I
PREVIOUSLY STATED -- WE ARE
OBSERVING COVER NINETEEN SAFETY
CONSIDERATIONS WHICH MEANS
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM -- IT ALSO MEANS
THAT WE HAVE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE TESTIFYING NOT JUST IN THIS
ROOM BUT AT OUR WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM AS WELL AS
OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS
AS WELL AS FOR MODERATE A
TELEPHONE SERVICE WHERE THE
CALL IN NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN ACCESS CODE ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO
IF ANYONE HAS ANY QUESTIONS
YOU CAN CALL COMMITTEE AT NINE
SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO
EIGHT FIVE AND WE ARE ALSO
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
ARE AND I'LL JUST MENTION THAT
FOR ME WITNESSES EITHER SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION EACH BUILDING
UP TO THE MAIN WITNESSES
WILL GET TWO MINUTES EACH AND
THEN FOR ALL OF THE WITNESSES
WHEN CALLING TO REGISTER YOUR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION PLEASE STATE
ONLY YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION FOR
SENATE BILL WITH THAT WE HAVE
FIVE BILLS ON OUR GENDER WE
HAVE TWO BILLS ON CONSENT I'D
LIKE TO TAKE A MOTION TO BEFORE
THE CONSENT AGENDA IS THERE
SECOND SECOND THERE'S A MOTION
AND A SECOND ITEM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SO SB
FOUR THREE TWO TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
AND SB FIVE EIGHTY ONE TO PASS
TO THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SHE'LL SHE'LL
I'D SAY ARE TÔI C.
R.
TO AYE GABRIEL GABRIEL I KALRA
KILEY KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
QUICK SILVA QUIKSILVER I WICKS
LICKS I CONSENT TO JUMP PASSES
THAT'S NOT GOING FALL WATER
TO FILE ITEM ONE SB THREE
NINETY ONE SENATOR MEN THANK
YOU FOR PATIENTS THANK YOU
CHURCHILL THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
OF AND WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL SB THREE NINETY ONE
AS AN EMERGENCY MEASURE THAT
AUTHORIZES COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENT BOARDS INCLUDING
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS TO
SAFELY MEET VIA TELECONFERENCE
DURING EMERGENCIES AND
DISASTERS INSURERS THAT FAIR
PARTICIPATION IN THESE MEETINGS
IS ASSESSABLE TO MEMBERS
IN RESPONSE TO THE ONGOING
PANDEMIC THE GOVERNOR ISSUED
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER LAST YEAR
ALLOWING LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
STATE AGENCIES TO MEET AND
VOTE REMOTELY YOU KNOW SIMILAR
ACTION HAS YET BEEN TAKEN
FOR HOAS THE DAVIS STERLING
COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENT ACT
REQUIRES A CHOICE TO PROVIDE A
PHYSICAL MEETING LOCATION FOR
ALL TELECONFERENCE MEETINGS
WHICH AS YOU CAN IMAGINE AS
POSE A SIGNIFICANT HEALTH RISK
IN THE MIDST OF THE ONGOING
PANDEMIC IN THE LAST YEAR HOAS
HAVE FOUND THAT IT ORGANIZING
IN PERSON MEETINGS AS CURRENTLY
REQUIRED UNDER EXISTING LAW HAS
OFTEN BEEN IMPRACTICAL ON SAFE
OR EVEN LEGAL SOME OF THESE
HOAS HAVE CONDUCTED MEETINGS
BY VIDEO OR PHONE WITH LIMITED
OR NO PROCEDURES IN RESPONSE
TO THIS CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
LAW REVISION COMMISSION WORK
LAST FALL TO CRAFT A VERY
NARROW POLICY RECOMMENDATION
AND THAT IS WHAT SITS BEFORE
YOU TODAY SB THREE NINETY ONE
SIMPLY WAIVE THE REQUIREMENT
TO PROVIDE AN IN PERSON MEETING
LOCATION FOR TELECONFERENCE
MEETINGS DURING A DECLARED
EMERGENCY OR DISASTER AND
PROVIDES PROCEDURES FOR THOSE
TELECONFERENCE MEETINGS TO
ENSURE THAT PARTICIPATION IS
FULLY ACCESSIBLE TO MEMBERS
THIS BILL REQUIRES HOAS
TO FULFILL THE FOLLOWING
REQUIREMENTS THEY MUST
PROVIDE CLEAR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO PARTICIPATE THE MEETING
NOTICE MUST INCLUDE THE
TELEPHONE NUMBER AND EMAIL
OF A PERSON WHO CAN PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WITH THE
TELECONFERENCE PROCESS BOTH
BEFORE AND DURING THE MEETING
THEY MUST ENSURE THAT EVERY
DIRECTOR AND MEMBER HAS THE
SAME ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE MEETING THAT WOULD EXIST IF
THE MEETING WERE HELD IN PERSON
ANY VOTE OF THE DIRECTOR SHALL
BE CONDUCTED BY A ROLL CALL
VOTE AND LASTLY PARTICIPATION
PRESIDENT SHALL BE GIVEN THE
OPTION OF PARTICIPATING BY
PHONE FROM WILDFIRES TO GLOBAL
PANDEMICS RECENT EMERGENCIES
IN CALIFORNIA SHOWED HAVE SHOWN
THAT IS NOT ALWAYS POSSIBLE
OR SAFE FOR -- SOCIAL ASIANS
TO PROVIDE IN PERSON MEETING
LOCATIONS THAT IS WHY SB THREE
NINETY ONE A PERMISSIVE BILL
THAT SIMPLY GIVES H.
AWAY AS ANOTHER OPTION TO
MEET SAFELY DURING TIMES OF
EMERGENCIES AGAIN THE SAME
OPTION THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
EXTENDED THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND STATE AGENCIES IS SO
URGENTLY NEEDED TODAY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY WE HAVE
BRIAN A PAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LAW REVISION COMMISSION
AND -- PATCHELL A COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATION ATTORNEY THE
ATTORNEY FROM ORANGE COUNTY
WHOSE FIRM PROVIDES LEGAL
COUNSEL FOR HUNDREDS OF
ASSOCIATIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR LET'S NOW GO
TO THE FIRST WITNESSES ARE
ONLY BRIAN HUBERT AND DARK
PATCHELL TO THE OPERATOR
GOOD AFTERNOON --
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN INDEED
THIS IS BRIAN HIBBARD ON THE
DIRECTOR OF THE LAW REVISION
COMMISSION AS SENATOR MAN
EXPLAINED -- THIS BILL IS BASED
ON A COMMISSION RECOMMENDATION
I AM AVAILABLE TODAY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
ABOUT THE THE COMMISSION'S
RECOMMENDATION ALL EXPLAIN
ANYTHING THOUGH IT IS UNCLEAR
-- THE ONLY OTHER THING I
WOULD ADD IS THAT THE THE
COMMISSION PROPOSED THAT THIS
URGENCY BILL BECAUSE WE HAD
HEARD IN OUR MEETINGS WITH
THAT MANY ASSOCIATIONS WERE
ALREADY HOLDING MEETINGS
BY TELECONFERENCE WITHOUT
PROVIDING ANY POLLUTION
LOCATION IN VIOLATION OF
EXISTING LAW AND -- THAT
EXPOSES ALL THE DECISIONS MADE
AT THOSE MEETINGS TO BEING
CHALLENGED AS ON LONG ISLAND SO
WE WANTED TO GET C.
ID'S BACK ON A LAWFUL PUTTING
FOR THEIR MEETINGS AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE TO MINIMIZE THAT
COMPLICATION -- THAT THAT'S ALL
THE THAT I HAVE TO SAY AND LIKE
I SAID I'M AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S GO TO THE NEXT WITNESS
CHAIRPERSON CHIU AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS THIS IS YOUR PATCHELL
AND AS WAS MENTIONED BY
SENATOR -- THAT I MEAN I AM
AN ATTORNEY WE REPRESENT THAT
YOU MIGHT FOR MANY HUNDREDS OF
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS IN THE
STATE OF THE COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS IN COMMUNITIES
ARE GOVERNED BY A VOLUNTEER
HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE REQUIRED TO
ACT IN PART THROUGH THE OPEN
OPEN MEETINGS OF THE BOARD
AND AS WITH STATED EARLIER
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES THAT
THESE OPEN MEETINGS PROVIDE
FOR A PHYSICAL LOCATION FOR
THE ASSOCIATION MEMBERS TO
ATTEND EVER AS WE ALL KNOW IN
THE LAST SIXTEEN MONTHS LOCAL
AND STATE MANDATES PREVENTED
THOSE PHYSICAL GATHERINGS
AND EVEN IF TECHNICALLY
NOT PROHIBITED VOLUNTEER
BOARD MEMBERS RESIDENTS AND
PROFESSIONAL MANAGEMENT HAD
SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT HOLDING
OF PHYSICAL LOCATIONS OPEN AS
SUCH IT VERY CRITICAL EXTREMELY
BUSY TIME AND AGAIN IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IT BECAME VERY
DIFFICULT FOR A VOLUNTEER BOARD
TO DO THEIR JOB BY NECESSITY
TO BROWN ACTED OTHER LAWS WERE
QUICKLY MODIFIED BUT DID SEE
A COMMON INTEREST COMMUNITIES
DID NOT SEE THAT RELIEF SO
NONETHELESS EVEN WITHOUT THE
CHANGE TO THE LAW AT DRIVEN
BY THE SAME NECESSITIES OF
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES AND
WITH SOME PROTECTION FROM OUR
GOVERNOR'S ORDERS COMMENTED OUR
COMMUNITY STARTED CONDUCTING
THEIR OPEN MEETINGS BY VIDEO
CONFERENCE AND DISCUSS ENABLED
OUR COMMUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
FUNCTION WHILE PROTECTING ALL
INVOLVED FROM THAT EXPOSURE TO
CO THAT AT THAT POINT WE SAW
SOMETHING REALLY INTERESTING
START TO HAPPEN ACROSS THE
BOARD WE STOCK IN UNITY
ATTENDANCE AND INVOLVEMENT
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASING A
COUPLE OF EXAMPLES HERE IN
ORANGE COUNTY BOTH ARE AGE
RESTRICTED COMMUNITIES ONE
WITH A THOUSAND DOORS -- AND
HOMES CORDED IF MORE THAN A
HUNDRED PERCENT INCREASE IN
PARTICIPATION IN THE MEETINGS
ONCE THEY WENT ONLINE WE
HAVE ANOTHER AGE RESTRICTED
COMMUNITY UP TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED HOMES THAT ARE IS
REPORTING GREATER THAN THREE
HUNDRED PART -- PERCENT
INCREASE IN PARTICIPATION
SB THREE NINETY ONE VERY
SIMPLY ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES DURING
TIMES OF EMERGENCY AND ALLOWS
THEM TO CONDUCT THEIR BOARD
MEETINGS WITHOUT A PHYSICAL
LOCATION IN A MANNER JUST
LIKE THIS CALL ALL OF THIS
WHILE ENHANCING NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS ENHANCING THE
TECHNICAL SUPPORT REQUIREMENTS
AND WHILE MAINTAINING ALL
THE PRE EXISTING COMMUNITY
RECORD KEEPING REQUIREMENTS
SO FOR THAT PROTECTION OF
OUR RESIDENTIAL COMMUNITIES
AND THOSE WHO LIVE WITHIN
THEM I PERSONALLY URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT SB THREE NINETY ONE
WITH YOUR VOTE TODAY AND I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
I'LL REMAIN ON THE LINE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS THAT MAY ARISE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S NOW
GO TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE TO OUR
HUNDRED KELLY AND TOM SERVER
IF THE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE ALLOW THEM TO SPEAK
HELLO LIKE WE CAN ORGANISE
CAL OKAY THANK YOU MY NAME
IS KELLY AND I AM NOT A
LAWYER I AM VERY LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LINE WHICH RETIRED AMERICANS
WE HAVE OVER A MILLION MEMBERS
WE HAVE MANY MEMBERS WHO
ARE ALSO DISABLED INVOLVED
REALLY LIKE A VERY GOOD START
NOT A BIG DEAL AND IT'S NOT
EVEN A GOOD DEAL CALIFORNIA
WANT TO TIRED AMERICANS EACH
ALL FOR ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
SENIORS LIVING IN CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
THE BILL WOULD BE A BASE
MOLDING RIGHT TO ENSURE
THAT ASSOCIATION ALEXION ARE
CLEAN AND FAIR BY ELIMINATING
THE REQUIREMENT THAT THERE
IS A PHYSICAL LOCATION FOR
HEATING YOU ARE ALL WHAT
APPEARS TO ON THE BALLOT
WHAT'S UP TO CAMERA COLOR
SOLUTION ESPECIALLY FOR
SENIORS THAT HAVE NO INTERNET
NO CELL PHONE AND THERE ARE
MANY OF US DO NOT HAVE EITHER
TRANSPARENCY IN ELECTIONS AND
NEEDING HUGE ISSUE WAS IN THE
NOVEMBER PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
EVERY ELECTION THE ALL THE
WHITE OF FOR PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO WITNESS AND MONITOR
THE HARM COUNTING OF BALLOTS
TO BE ABLE TO AND HERE AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS GOING ON
IT'S IMPORTANT TRANSPARENCY
IS ALSO A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT
BECAUSE EACH ELECTION THREE
NINE ONE TAKE AWAY THAT RIGHT
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CLUB THERE ANOTHER LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT AND EFFECTIVE DAILY
LIFE PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
SUCH I KNOW THAT YOU ARE
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK ON THE
PHONE HERE I KNOW THAT THERE
IS A VERY GOOD THING I KNOW
HAVING THESE VERY IMPORTANT
THAT YOU UNDERSTAND THAT NOT
EVERYONE THEY DID NOT HAVE CELL
PHONES SH AND MANY PEOPLE AB A
REQUIREMENT ON THE CALL E.
D.
A.
R.
WIREIMAGE FIFTY EIGHT I'M MORE
I DON'T THINK THEY'RE THEY'RE
BUILT WEEK URGING NO VOTE
IN NINETY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISS KELLY LET'S
NOT GO TO MISTER SERVER
THANK YOU -- THIS IS TOM
SIR I'M ON THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE OF THE CENTER
FOR CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION LAW WHICH IS THE
PROBLEM SB THREE NINETY ONE
BECAUSE OF ITS PROVISION IN
PROPOSED SECTION FIFTY FOUR
FIFTY DE THAT PERMIT THE
CANCELLATION OF THE OTHERWISE
REQUIRED IN PERSON MEETING
TO WITNESS ACCOUNTING ABOUT
THIS PROVISION HAS BEEN AND
COMPLETELY UNDERMINED THE
INTEGRITY AND CREDIBILITY OF
THE VOTE YOU WILL TAKE THE
HAZARD OF SUBSTITUTING VIRTUAL
MEETING IN PLACE OF THE REAL
THING WE PRESENT THREE CAN BE
REAL EXAMPLES OF WHICH WE ARE
AWARE VENTURA COUNTY ELECTION
GROUP BOARD OF DIRECTORS IN
MARCH THE INSPECTOR CONDUCTED
THE TABULATION IN ANOTHER
COUNTY AND NO IN PERSON
BUT NOTHING WAS COMMITTED
HOMOTHETIC VIDEO LINK THE WERE
UNABLE TO CREATE A BALANCE AND
WE'RE SHOWN ONLY A SPREADSHEET
WITH THE TABULATION PROVOKED IN
LOS ANGELES NATURE WE ELECTION
IN APRIL THE COUNTING WAS DONE
DURING THE MEETING WITH THE
WHOLE OF THE BOARD BRADLEY IN
THE PAST TEN YEARS ALLOWED ONLY
FIVE MEMBERS INTO THE BEATING
AND LEFT MANY OTHERS OUT AND
ALL THAT COULD BE VIEWED BUT
THE TOP OF THE INSPECTOR CARE
ACT AND NO ONE CAN SEE WHAT HE
WAS ACTUALLY DOING THE WORST
EXAMPLE OCCURRED TWO WEEKS AGO
WHAT A LOS ANGELES H.
AWAY HELD A VOTE COUNTY MEETING
ON THE PHONE WITH NO VIDEO AT
ALL HAVE BEEN DECLARED BECAUSE
THE DEATH OF HOSTED VOTE WITH
THE APPROVAL OF THE FESTIVAL
SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
OWN FINAL POINT THE PETITION
WHICH WE ARE OBJECTING TO
COMPLETELY UNDER DURING DURING
LAST NOVEMBER'S PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION WIN THE COPA NINETY
AM DEADLY CORRELATING THERE
WERE NO CANCELLATIONS WITHIN
PERSON WITNESSING A BALLOT
COUNTY ANYWHERE IN THE UNITED
STATES THE ONE ACCEPTS FULL
WALKTHROUGH GUIDE WITH SCORES
OF UNSUCCESSFUL CHALLENGES
FILED ON BEHALF OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT HAD TO DO WITH THE
WITNESSING OF DALLAS COUNTY
PENNSYLVANIA THE PROVISION
PROJECT -- INHABITANTS IT
DOESN'T WORK AND IT'S NOT
NECESSARY WE HAVE OFFERED AN
AMENDMENT THAT WE THINK SHOULD
BE ACCEPTABLE TO THE OFFICE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE OFFICE OFFICE ON THE LEAN
SIDE WHERE IT'S A NO VOTE ON
IT TWO THREE NINE ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU LET'S NOT BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
C.
NON I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD WE KNOW THAT
PARTICULAR DURING THIS TIME
PERIOD -- IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US TO PROVIDE A TWO WAYS WITH
SOME GUIDANCE AND HAVE A HOLD
REMOTE TELECONFERENCE MEETINGS
DURING THESE EMERGENCIES ARE
WALL I THINK WE ALL HOPE THAT
THE WORST OF CO THAT IS BEHIND
US ON THIS NEED CONTINUES
ALSO WANT TO JUST NOTE THAT
THIS BILL EXPLICITLY GIVES
MEMBERS OF HOAS EXACT SAME
PARTICIPATION ABILITIES AS
IF THEY WERE IN AN IN PERSON
MEETING AND WE'VE ALSO --
PLACE VERY NARROW CIRCUMSTANCES
WHEN A PHYSICAL MEETING WOULD
NOT BE POSSIBLE SO WELL WITH
THAT LESSER ANY FINAL COMMENTS
I WANT TO TURN IT BACK TO
THE CENTER TO MAKE ANY FINAL
CLOSING APPS THANK YOU TRICKS
-- -- I WOULD JUST RESPOND TO
THE OPPOSITION VERY QUICKLY
BY POINTING OUT THAT AS YOU
MENTIONED THIS IS A PERMISSIVE
BILL THAT IS VERY NARROW IN ITS
SCOPE AND AS FAR AS ELECTIONS
I WOULD ACTUALLY ARGUE THAT THE
TESTIMONY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION LAW
PROVES OUR POINT WHICH IS THAT
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS ARE
ALREADY ENGAGING IN ELECTIONS
REMOTELY BECAUSE THERE'S NO
GUIDANCE ARBIL SPECIFICALLY
STATES THAT YOU CAN ONLY HAVE
A REMOTE ELECTION WHEN THERE
IS A DECLARED OR PROCLAIM
DISASTER EMERGENCY THAT MAKES
IT UNSAFE OR IMPOSSIBLE FOR
PEOPLE TO GATHER IN PERSON IT
EXPLICITLY REQUIRES THAT THOSE
MEETING THOSE BALLOTS HAVE TO
BE COUNTED AND TABULATED BY
VIDEO CONFERENCE IN FRONT OF
A CAMERA IN A LOCATION SUCH
THAT MEMBERS CAN WITNESS THE
INSPECTOR OF ELECTIONS COUNTING
AND TABULATING THE VOTES ARE
THOSE PROCEDURES DO NOT EXIST
RIGHT NOW AND -- I THINK THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT BILL AYE I
WOULD ARGUE IT IS A GOOD BILL
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU WANNA GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS ALLOW MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC PROPERTY CREE
WERE ON THE PHONE LINES TO
EITHER STATE THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE --
SO WITH THAT IF WE COULD GO
TO THE OPERATOR IF YOU CORD
THE LINES FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AND IF YOU SUPPORTER
POSSIBILE SIMPLY STATE THAT
FACT YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
THANK YOU IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT OF
SB THREE NINETY ONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT MY MOMENT WE DO
HAVE A FEW KEY WERE NOT
WE JUST HAVE TO GIVE MY LINE
NUMBER AND AGAIN IT'S FOR
SUPPORT AND OR OPPOSITION SB
THREE NINETY ONE AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE OF SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN CHAIRED
MEMBERS JENNIFER WATER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COMMUNITY
MANAGERS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU MEXICO TO ALAINA
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN THANK YOU OPERATOR
EDWARD CHESHIRE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY FORMER BOARD MEMBER
OF PACIFIC RIDGE NEIGHBORHOOD
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU AND ACCESSIBLE TO
LINE UP EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR
ME OK YES HELLO OKAY MY NAME IS
GUS PETRA BORG I'M THE H.
AWAY OWNER AND
FORMER MORE A FORMER H.
AWAY DIRECTOR FROM
PLASTER COUNTY AND I
AM OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME WE
CAN HEAR YOU YES YOU CAN
HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU
YES I'M GAIL MARTIN IN A
SAN DIEGO COUNTY HOMEOWNER
AND -- BOARD MEMBERS --
OPPOSED TO STILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND ACCESSIBLE TO
LINE OF SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN HI I MIGRATE TO SWEENEY
-- FIND THAT NUMBER IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY AND A FORMER BOARD
MEMBER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF
NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN HI MY NAME IS TINA
MONDRAGON'S MEDINA CITY CODE
MORE MEN ERA FORMER BOARD
MEMBER AND I OPPOSE THESE DEAL
THANK YOU EXOBYTES A LINE OF
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CARLOS INSURANCE
ON BEHALF OF THE COMMITTEE
ASSOCIATION IT'S TO SUPPORT
THANK YOU AN EXTROVERT SO
LINE OF NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN HI MY NAME IS DELORES
LUCARELLI I'M ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS I'M A SENIOR I MEAN
SAN DIEGO CAN SIX SAN DIEGO
COUNTY SAN DIEGO CITY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AGAIN ANY DISCUSSION
IS A MOTION WITH THE BILL FOR
THE SECOND THERE'S A SECOND
AND WITHOUT ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY Q.
R.
TWO R.
I.
C.
R.
TÔI SERTA I'D GABRIEL KALRA
KILEY KILEY I'D MAIENSCHEIN
QUICK SILVA KIRK SILVA AYE
LICKS THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES
ON THE BILLS WERE VOTED ON CALL
WAIT FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO COME
ABOUT THANK YOU LET'S NOT GO TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB THREE
NINETY TWO SENATOR ARCHULETA
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I WOULD LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND
PRESENT SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY TWO AND I'M HERE TO --
SHARE THIS WITH YOU BECAUSE
IT IS AN IMPORTANT BILL AND
I THINK IT DOES MAKE A LOT
OF HEADWAY HERE I WOULD LIKE
TO START BY THANKING THE
CHAIR THANK YOU SIR AND YOUR
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH ME ON
THIS BILL AND I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS AND THEY PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS ON SENATE BILL
THREE NINETY TWO WILL REQUIRE
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS TO
ANNUALLY ASK OUR MEMBERS
TO PROVIDE THE FOLLOWING
INFORMATION AN EMAIL AND
MAILING ADDRESS A SECONDARY
EMAIL AND THE SECONDARY
MAILING ADDRESS ADDITIONALLY
AT THIS POINT AT THIS TIME
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
MEMBERS PICK THEIR PREFERRED
DOCUMENTS DELIVERY METHOD OF
EITHER EMAIL OR PAPER NOTICES
UNDER THE DAVIS STERLING ACT
ASSOCIATIONS ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE MEMBERS WITH NECESSARY
DOCUMENTS INCLUDING ANNUAL
BUDGETS POLICY STATEMENTS
AND OR NOTICES PREVIOUS
LITIGATION HAS SOUGHT TO
PROTECT HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
MEMBERS FROM EXORBITANT FEES
RELATED TO DOCUMENT DELIVERY
BY LIMITING THE AMOUNT OF
ASSOCIATIONS CAN CHARGE FOR
THESE REASONS AND AND AT THIS
APPROPRIATE TIME I THINK THAT
WE WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THE FEES SOMETIMES AND COSTS
ASSOCIATED UP OUR LITTLE TOO
MUCH AND -- TRADITIONALLY TO
FURTHER INCREASE INFORMATION
ACCESSIBILITY LEGISLATURES
PASSED SENATE BILL THREE
TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY
NINETEEN WHICH REQUIRES
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS TO
DELIVER MEMBERSHIP BOARD
ELECTION RULES BY INDIVIDUAL
DELIVERY OR BY POSTING ON
A WEBSITE IN THE MISTER
GLOBAL PANDEMIC WERE MAIL
DELIVERIES ARE DELAYED THERE
IS VERY COMMON COST SAVINGS
ARE CRITICAL AND CRUCIAL
INFORMATION ACCESSIBILITY IS
VITAL UPDATING THESE DELIVERY
METHODS TO ALLOW FOR MORE
MEMBERS TO CHOOSE EMAIL AS
YOUR PREFERRED DELIVERY METHOD
IS CRITICAL UNDER CURRENT LAW
THE DEFAULT DOCUMENT DELIVERY
METHOD HIS TRADITIONAL MAIL
THIS BILL IS PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED PROVIDES PREFERRED
DOCUMENT DELIVERY OPTIONS OF
TRADITIONAL MAIL OR EMAIL TO
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION MEMBERS
AND AT THE SAME TIME DO IT IN
A TIMELY AND SECURE DELIVERY
SYSTEM WITH SECONDARY BACKUP
OPTIONS AND A NEW DEFINITION
OF VALID EMAIL ADDRESSES THE
BILL IS AVAILABLE TO ENSURE
THAT DOCUMENT DELIVERIES
AT HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS
ARE KEPT UP TO DATE WITH IN
OUR EVER CHANGING LANDSCAPE
OF INFORMATION SHARING
TECHNOLOGIES THIS BILL RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND PASSED
OFF THE SENATE FLOOR WITH NO
NO VOTES FOR THESE REASONS AT
THE PROPER TIME MISTER CHAIR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS AND THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND I THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME THIS TIME IN WITH ME ON
THE PHONE AND THE LINE IS
JENNIFER SETBACK REPRESENTING
THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL WHICH
IS THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS SHE WILL ALSO
BE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IF YOU
HAVE ANY THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER LET'S NOW GO TO YOUR
FIRST AND ONLY WITNESS TO
MASS SPEC WILLIAMS ARE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
REALTORS TO THE OPERATOR
I'M NOT SURE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY --
WE ARE THE SPONSORS OF SB THREE
NINETY TWO IT'S HIGH TIME THAT
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REQUIRE HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS
TO DELIVER DOCUMENTS VIA
EMAIL PER THE HOMEOWNERS
FOR A CLASS I IT'S IT'S PAST
TIME FOR US TO COME UP WITH
TECHNOLOGY AND WE APPRECIATE
YOU CONSIDERING THE BILL WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS EFFORTS IN CARRYING THE
MEASURE IN YOUR STOPS WORK ON
THE RECENT AMENDMENTS WHAT THAT
WAS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
VOTE I'LL BE HERE IF ANYBODY
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
THIS TIME LET'S NOW GO TO THE
WITNESSES FOR THE OPPOSITION
WE HAVE TO -- IS MARJORIE MARIE
FROM THE CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION LAW
AND MS ELAINE LET LOVE PLANTS
ALSO WERE FROM THE CENTER FOR
CALIFORNIA EACH TO A LAW CENTER
IONISATION TO THE OPERATOR
TO THE OPERATOR
WITNESSES LINES ARE OPEN
MS MURRAY YOUR
MIND YOU'RE A LOT
PLEASE GO I AM A LAYING LEAD
LAP PLANT MARJORIE WAS GOING TO
SPEAK MISS MARIE WAS GOING TO
SPEAK FIRST -- AND SHE WAS ON
THE LINE MARJORIE ARE YOU THERE
OKAY I WILL GO AHEAD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHIU AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE SIX SB THREE
NINETY TWO HE IS TRYING TO IS
AN EIGHT BILLION H.
AWAY ASSOCIATIONS TO EXEMPT
THEMSELVES FROM THE CONSUMER
PRODUCT FOR THE C.
PROTECTION LAWS AND ESPECIALLY
THOSE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
ARE MORE RESTRICTIVE THAN
MANY OTHER STATES B.
BUT STATE AND FEDERAL PRIVACY
LAWS HOLD THAT EMAIL ACCOUNTS
ARE PERSONAL NON PUBLIC
INFORMATION INCIDENT INDIVIDUAL
IN HIS NAME THAT I EMAIL
ACCOUNT HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED
ALAIN VIGNEAULT OKAY THE EMAIL
ACCOUNT IS A PROPERTY OF THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO CREATED THE
ACCOUNT AND ONLY THAT PERSON
CAN AUTHORIZE WHETHER OR
NOT THE PERSONAL EMAIL BAIT
MAY BE USED FOR RECEIPT OF
EMAIL COMMUNICATION AND HE
SPECIFICALLY WHAT DOCUMENT
WHAT COMMUNICATION MAYBE
WE SEE THAT EMAIL SB THREE
NINETY TWO ONE THE COURTS
TO OFFER AN ALTERNATIVE FOR
THE EMAIL HOLDER COCKTAIL IT
DOES NOT SPECIFICALLY DEFINE
THE METHODOLOGY IS OPTING OUT
FOR WHAT DOC YET THEY OFTEN
SPECIFICALLY WHAT DOCUMENTS
WOULD BE PREACHING AROUND
WOULD BE PRODUCED THROUGH THAT
EMAIL IT ALSO REQUIRES TWO
EMAIL ACCOUNTS WHICH IS REALLY
SUPERFLUOUS WE ONLY HAVE ONE
PHYSICAL MAILING ADDRESS IF I'M
GOING TO RECEIVE EMAILS UNLIKE
TRYING TO CREATE I AM GOING TO
GIVE ONE ADDRESS NOT MULTIPLE
ADDRESSES SHELL THAT THEY GAIN
I YES MY INFORMATION THAT I AM
SHARING THAT IS PRICELESS TO
ME AND SB THIRTY THREE NINETY
TWO IS SEEKING TO AVOID THESE
CRITTERS THE REQUIREMENTS
THERE'S NO PROVISION IN THAT
FOR DISCLOSURE AND THEREFORE
THEY CAN STAND ELEMENT OF
PREGNANCY AND ACCEPTANCE
BARDINI GATE AT FULL SAIL SB
THREE NINETY TWO AGAIN DOES NOT
DISCLOSE TO THE MEMBERSHIP WHAT
INFORMATION IS BEING COLLECTED
FOR WHAT PURPOSE IT WILL BE
A USED WHO IS IT GOING TO BE
ASSESSMENT HAD DISSEMINATED
TREAT WE ALL KNOW THAT EVERY
OTHER AGENCY BUSINESS MYSELF
INCLUDED I HAVE TO PROVIDE OUR
CLIENTS WITH DISCLOSURES ANY
PERSONAL NON PUBLIC INFORMATION
REQUIRES DISCLOSURE IT ALSO
REQUIRES HOW WE ARE PROTECTING
IT AND THE PURPOSE OF WHICH
IS GOING TO BE USED THAT MUST
BE PROVIDED ANNUALLY IT MUST
TELL ME HOW I CAN YEAH YEAH
FINALLY WITH SB THREE THIRTY
TWO AND WHAT IS TO BE PROVIDED
THERE ARE MANY NOTICES UNDER
THE DAY THE STERLING ACT THAT
MUST BE PROVIDED ON PAPER IN
PERSON PERSONAL DILLON THREE
SELL GIVEN ALL THE DIFFERENT
ASPECTS TO WHICH MADE HOMEOWNER
BOARD CONDUCTS ITS BUSINESS
I WOULDN'T WANT MY PERSONAL
INFORMATION BEING SENT TO A
COLLECTION AGENCY BECAUSE I
WAS OUT OF TOWN AND MISS THE
PAYMENT OF MY MONTHLY DUES
OR IF MY INSURANCE LAPSED OR
WHAT HAVE YOU IF I AGREE TO
RECEIVE INFORMATION IT NEEDS
TO BE I WANTED TO KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT IT IS I'M AUTHORIZING I
HAVE TO AUTHORIZE ANY OTHER
COMPANY I DO BUSINESS WITH I
SPECIFICALLY AUTHORIZED WHAT
INFORMATION I'M AUTHORIZING
TO BE TRANSMITTED TO ME A LACK
TRYING TO CREATE THEREFORE
IN CONCLUSION HLA BOARDS YES
EMAIL DELIVERY IS EFFICIENT
IT CAN'T BE COST SAVINGS BUT
THAT MUST COMPLY WITH RULE AND
REGULATION JUST AS EVERY OTHER
BUSINESS CASTING IS STILL THERE
FOR ME TELL THIS UNTIL THERE
ARE AMENDMENTS AND THAT COMPLY
WITH EXISTING LAW I URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE NOW THANK
YOU THANK YOU LET'S GO TO THE
NEXT WITNESS TWO MINUTES PLEASE
TO THE NEXT WITNESS
THANKS VERY ARE YOU THERE
MERRY
CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES YOUR MAKE UP YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU'LL PLEASE CONTINUE
HE I WANT TO EMPHASIZE ONE
POINT THAT -- THIS PLANT IS
MAKING IN HER PRESENTATION SHE
COMPLIANCE OFFICER WITH MORE
THAN TWENTY YEARS EXPERIENCE
IN BANKING REQUIRING DETAILED
COMPLIANCE WITH BOTH STATE AND
FEDERAL LAWS ON PRIVACY WHAT
IS MISSING FROM THIS BILL FROM
SB THREE NINETY TWO IS A VERY
BASIC REQUIREMENTS THAT THE
ASSOCIATION OF CHAMBER CONSENT
OF THE HOMEOWNER THIS IS A
CORD ASIAN OF STATE AND FEDERAL
PRIVACY LAWS A PRIVATE EMAIL
ADDRESS CANNOT BE USED UNLESS
AND UNTIL THE CONSENT OF THE
OWNER OF THAT EMAIL ADDRESS
HAS BEEN OBTAINED THAT IS SO
IMPORTANT MISSING INGREDIENT
FROM THIS BILL HIT BASICALLY
IS TRYING TO EXEMPT HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATIONS FROM COMPLIANCE
WITH THAT ASCENTIAL INGREDIENTS
OF STATE AND FEDERAL PRIVACY
LAWS NSC HAS EMPHASIZED THERE
IS ALSO NO GUARANTEE OF WHAT
THE PROTECTIONS ARE ONE THE
HOMEOWNER EMAIL DATABASE HAVE
BEEN COMPILED NOR ARE THERE
ANY DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS AS
TO HOW THE DATABASE IS GOING
TO BE USED AND I DO WANT TO
STRESS THAT'S ALSO THE ASIAN
UNDER DAVID STERLING AND ALSO
UNDER THE FORECLOSURE STATUTES
ARE REQUIRED TO DELIVER THIRTY
LEGAL NOTICES IN A STATUTORILY
PRESCRIBED WAY THROUGH CERTAIN
METHODS FOR EXAMPLE THE NOTICE
OF ASSESSMENT CLEAN INDICATING
THAT ASSESSMENT CERTAINLY I
CAN'T PREDICT THAT UNDER THIS
STATUTE ASSOCIATIONS ARE GOING
TO START TO DELIVER LEGAL
NOTICES BY EMAIL BECAUSE THERE
IS NO PROHIBITION AGAINST
DOING THAT THIS IS NOT JUST A
MATTER OF DELIVERING FINANCIAL
REPORTS BUT THE LEVER AND
EVERYTHING UNDER THE SUN TO
THE HOMEOWNER TO AN EMAIL
ADDRESS NO MATTER HOW IT HAS
BEEN OBTAINED SO WE DO URGE A
NO VOTE ON SB THREE NINETY TWO
IT IS INSUFFICIENT TO FRAME
THIS AS A FISCAL AND COST
SAVING MEASURE BECAUSE THERE
ARE IMPORTANT DELIVERY AND
LEGAL RAMIFICATIONS TO IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN TOTALLY OVERLOOKED
THANK YOU I HEAR MUCH NOW LET'S
GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THEY WISH TO SPEAK IN PUBLIC
COMMENT EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL IF
YOU CAN PLEASE JUST CONNECTION
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION
AND WHY DO YOU SUPPORT
OR OPPOSE TO THE OPERATOR
THANK YOU IF YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THE SB THREE NINETY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO ONE
ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE NINETY TWO AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN HI THIS IS
EDWARD CHESHIRE FROM SAN DIEGO
-- FORMER BOARD MEMBERS OF THE
PACIFIC BRIDGE NEIGHBORHOOD
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU NXR GO TO LINE OF
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THREE YEAH HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY MY
NAME IS GUS FEDERAL BOARD BY
MANAGER WAY HOMEOWNER FORMER H.
AWAY DIRECTOR FROM PLASTER
COUNTY ALSO SENIOR CITIZEN
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU AND NEXT OVER TO LINE
OF SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD YES I'M GAIL MARTIN
FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY OUR
SENIOR IN A -- H.
AWAY FORMER BOARD MEMBER
I STRONGLY OPPOSED
THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU MEXICO SO LINE OF
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
HELLO ADME YES I CAN'T
WAIT EIGHT ONE STATE BOARD
PRESIDENT CLINTON YEARS
-- UNION CITY ALAMEDA
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB THREE NINETEEN I CAN'T
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THANK
YOU MARGARET SWEENEY CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY FORMER BOARD
MEMBER AND THE HOME OWNER --
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU ELECT ABOUT THE LINE
OF NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
I NEED TO HIDING EIGHT AM --
MONDRAGON MONEYNESS UNIQLO
FORMER BOARD MEMBER A NIGHT
COOL POSTS BCPL COMPLETELY
STE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU LET'S BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND
DISCUSSION TO THE MOISTURE
CENTER RIGHT HERE MY QUESTION
IS ABOUT SOME OF THE COMMENTS
ON THAT IF YOU'LL BE GIVING
UP THEIR EMAIL IF THEY DON'T
WANT TO GIVE UP THEIR EMAIL
AND THEY JUST WANT TO RECEIVE
IT BY MAIL THEY CAN DO THAT
WITHOUT PROVIDING THE OTHER
INFORMATION IS THAT CORRECT YES
MEMBER I I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT WITH AMENDMENTS THAT THE
CHAIRS ACCEPTED REMEMBER WE'RE
ONLY ASKING ANNUALLY IF THEY
LIKE A PARTICULAR METHOD WHICH
IS AGAIN EITHER EMAIL MAILING
ADDRESS AND THEY'RE ASKING FOR
SECONDARY IF IT GOES OUT AND
-- BECAUSE IT'S SO IMPORTANT
IN THE BUSINESS OF HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS ESPECIALLY WITH
LARGE ONES OVER ONE HUNDRED
TWO HUNDRED -- THINGS CHANGE
IN THE BUDGET ASSOCIATION FEES
IT IT COULD BE MEETING DATES
-- WE HEARD ABOUT ELECTIONS
PRIOR TO THIS MEETING -- IT
COULD BE ISSUES THAT EVERYONE
MUST BE OPEN MADE AWARE UP IN
WHATEVER COMMUNICATIONS I'VE
GOT TO GET OUT THERE THIS IS
THE BEST WAY TO DO IT THAT'S
ALL IT JUST COMMUNICATIONS
AND WITH THE TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
OUT THERE WE JUST WANT TO OPEN
THOSE DOORS SO IF THEY DON'T
WANT TO BE SUPPORTED IN OUR
MOUTHS AND THEY HAVE THE OPTION
TO SAY KEEP BE MAILING IT TO ME
AND I DON'T HAVE TO GET DOCTOR
DON'T EMAIL MAIL ALL RIGHT
I JUST WANTED I PROCEED ARE
THE AUTHOR EXCEPT IN OUR
COMMITTEE MINUTES REALLY TO
MAKE THAT CLEAR SO ON THE
COMMITTEE MEMONS AGAIN ALLOW
A JURY MEMBERS TO ELECT WHICH
FORM OF NOTICE THEY WANT TO
PROVIDE EMAIL PAPER OR BOTH
NEITHER WOULD BE THE DEFAULT
BUT IF THE INDIVIDUAL DOESN'T
PROVIDE AN EMAIL ADDRESS AND
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO GET
PAPER NOTICES SO I THINK THIS
REALLY DOES SORT OF BALANCE --
I THINK THE INTEREST WILL HAVE
TO NOT INSURE THAT TO MINIMIZE
PAPER WASTE BUT ALSO ENSURING
THAT FOLKS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CHOOSE THE DELIVERY METHOD
THAT IS SUITED TO THEIR
NEEDS SO WITH THAT MR KILEY
SO I GOT ABOUT POINT BUT ON THE
OTHER HAND THIS BILL DOESN'T
JUST AUTHORIZED THE H.
AWAY TO SEND THESE -- NOTICES
ELECTRONICALLY BUT ACTUALLY --
REQUIRES THEM TO RIDE SO THAT
KINDA SEEMS LIKE SOMETHING
THAT'S PRETTY SPECIFIC FOR
US TO BE DECIDING ON BEHALF
OF EVERY CHOICE WHY NOT JUST
MAKE IT AUTHORIZED AS OPPOSED
TO WELL MANDATORY WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT YOUR HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION I SHARE THIS WITH
SO MANY I'VE BEEN BROUGHT
REAL ESTATE BROKER FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND WHEN
YOU PURCHASE A HOMEOWNERS --
WELL YOU PURCHASED A TOWNHOUSE
CONDOMINIUM WHATEVER THE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION AND
THE STRUCTURE IS SO VITAL IN
THAT PURCHASE PEOPLE DON'T
REALIZE BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH REVENUES IF YOU
DON'T HAVE IN US -- -- BACKING
FROM THE PRESIDENT AND SOME
OF THE BOARD MAINTENANCE IS
SO IMPORTANT THE BUDGET IS SO
IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO ANALYZE
THESE DOCUMENTS IS SO IMPORTANT
AND IF THERE'S A CHANGE BECAUSE
REVITALIZING THE SWIMMING POOL
PLACING ROUGH SHOT AN INCREASE
IN FEES IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THEY COMMUNICATE THIS IS THE
JUST TO BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE
IN EVERY POSSIBLE WAY WE CAN
AND WE HEARD EARLIER THAT NOW
IN THE WORLD OF ZOOMING THAT
THAT'S ALSO NOW ON THE TABLE
BUT WE'VE GOT TO KEEP THE
DOORS OPEN AS I KEEP SAYING
AND IT'S VITAL WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT CITY AND COUNTY
FUNCTIONS OR CITY OR COUNTY
REQUIREMENTS THAT MAY AFFECT
THE ASSOCIATION SO EVERYONE'S
GOT A NO AND AGAIN LIKE I SAID
THIS IS THAT EVERY ANNUAL SO
IT'S AN ANNUAL THING THEY'LL
CHECK AND RECHECK IF YOU WANT
TO GET IT BY EMAIL YOU WANT TO
GET IT BY MAIL IF YOU'VE BEEN
A CHANGE AND THAT'S IT AND
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO OPT OUT
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
MISS KRYSTAL
I'M HERE I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL I
I THINK THAT IT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT BILL AS WE SEEM
MANY OF OUR SENIORS LIVING
IN HOAS MY MOTHER LIVES IN
A CONDO ON AROUND AND I KNOW
THAT SOMETIMES CORRESPONDENT
HAS BEEN -- CORRESPONDENCES
BEEN VERY DELAYED IN SOME OF
THE MAJOR DECISIONS ASHY GETS
OLDER IT IS IMPORTANT -- THAT
SHE DOESN'T HAVE AN EMAIL SO
BEING ABLE TO HAVE THE CHOICE
FOR OUR FAMILY -- IT TO NOT
ONLY GET TO -- THE WRITTEN --
OR PAPER CORRESPONDENCE OR AN
EMAIL AS WELL OR BOTH IS REALLY
IMPORTANT -- BECAUSE AGAIN
THERE IS THAT CONSTITUENCY OF
SENIORS THAT DON'T INTERFACE
ON EMAIL BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT BILL BECAUSE ALL OF
THE FAMILIES THAT ARE INVOLVED
WITH -- SENIORS AS THEY AGE
ARE INVOLVED IN WANTING TO
KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THAT
PARTICULAR RESIDENTS THANK YOU
A FURTHER DISCUSSION POLITICS
WITHOUT CENTER ANY FINAL
COMMENTS WELL I WOULD SHE LIKE
TO THANK THE CHAIR AGAIN FOR
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS IN
THE MEMBERS I I THINK THIS IS
A A GOOD WAY TO TAKE CARE OF SO
MANY HOMEOWNERS AND TO PROTECT
THEIR COMMUNICATIONS AND AGAIN
AS WE HAD MENTIONED EARLIER
THAT THERE WERE NO NO VOTES
-- AND IT WAS -- BIPARTITION
ACROSS THE BOARD IN THE SENATE
AND I'D APPRECIATE -- YOUR --
PASSING THIS ON AND -- I URGE
A AYE VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR
WITH THAT IS OUR MOTION FOR AS
MOTIONS ARE SECOND THERE'S A
SECOND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY Q.
R.
Q.
I SEE OUR TO OUR TO OUR TO
OUR AYE GABRIEL GABRIEL I
KALRA KILEY MAIENSCHEIN CORK
SILVA AYE QUICK SILVA AYE
WITH SIX WEEKS I THE BILL HAS
FIVE OF YOUR BILL PASSES AWAY
FROM THE MEMBERS THANK YOU
MR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU AND
OUR FINAL ITEM OF THE DAY IS
FILE ITEM FIVE S.
B.
FIVE NINETY ONE SENATOR BACK
OR WELCOME TO THE HOUSING COULD
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS MY FIRST
BILL THE ASSEMBLY AND BY
HOPE IT DOESN'T OPENING UP
FOR ADDITIONAL HAZING I DID
WANT TO SAY IT'S A PLEASURE
TO PRESENT MY FIRST BILL THE
ASSEMBLY FOR THIS COMMITTEE
OF MY LONG TIME FRIENDS AT
YOUR DAVID CHIU WE JUST OPEN
YOURSELF UP THERE SEVEN ONE
PREPARE QUESTIONS PLEASE
SENATOR INTERGENERATIONAL
HOUSING MODELS ARE GROWING
IN POPULARITY ACROSS THE
NATION THEY SIMULTANEOUSLY
ADDRESS ISOLATION DEPRESSION
OFTEN SEEN IN SENIORS WELL
SUPPORTING VULNERABLE YOUTH AS
THEY TRANSITION OUT OF FOSTER
CARE AT THE FOSTER SYSTEM AND
ESTABLISH ALLIES AS INDEPENDENT
ADULTS OVER THERE'S BEEN AN
ISSUE BLOCKING THIS YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE IN
EMERYVILLE THE PROPOSED AN
INTERGENERATIONAL HOUSING
PROJECT THAT IS ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT AFFORDABLE THAT WOULD
INCLUDE SIXTY EIGHT UNITS
FOR SENIORS AND TRANSITION
AGE YOUTH BUT BEFORE HOUSING
PROJECTS FOR SENIORS THAT USED
TAX CREDITS WHICH IS NEARLY
ALL SUCH PROJECTS ARE CURRENTLY
PROHIBITED FROM INCLUDING
OTHER TYPES OF AFFORDABLE
UNITS IN THE SAME BUILDING
THAT'S DESPITE THE WELL
DOCUMENTED SOCIAL AND HEALTH
BENEFITS FOR SENIORS AND YOUTH
OF THIS KIND OF AFFORDABLE
INTERGENERATIONAL DEVELOPMENTS
DEFECTIVE WE PROHIBITED -- HERE
IN CALIFORNIA SO SB FIVE NINE
ONE ALLOWS TAX CREDIT FINANCED
AFFORDABLE INTERGENERATIONAL
HOUSING PROJECTS BONTA PROVIDED
AT LEAST EIGHTY PERCENT OF THE
UNITS ARE OCCUPIED BY SENIORS
IN UP TO TWENTY PERCENT ARE FOR
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH I WANT TO
KNOW THAT YOU APPRECIATE THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY LEADING H.
CALIFORNIA AND I WILL ADOPT A
PROPOSED AMENDMENT CLARIFYING
THAT FUNDING INTENDED FOR
SENIOR UNITS CAN ONLY BE USED
ON SENIOR UNITS -- -- FIND THAT
BEFORE THIS BILL IS HEARD IN
THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY THIS
BILL ROLE WE BELIEVE WILL
REDUCE YOUTH HOMELESSNESS
INCREASING FOR A HOUSING
PRODUCTION AND STRENGTHEN THE
FABRIC OF OUR COMMUNITIES I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE ON FIVE NINE ONE ON THE
LINE WITH BRIEF TESTIMONY IS
COUNCIL MEMBER JOHN WALTERS
CITY OF EMERYVILLE THANK YOU
LET'S NOT GO TO YOUR MAIN
WITNESS TO COUNCILMEMBER
POWDERS -- NOT A MODERATOR
THANK YOU LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU I BELIEVE
GOOD AFTERNOON -- CHURCH YOU IN
NUMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU TO
SENATOR BACKER FOR SPONSORING
SB FIVE NINETY ONE I COULD
NOT SAY ANYTHING BETTER THAN
THE STANDARD IN HIS SUMMARY I
JUST WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL IS THE
SPONSOR WE MAY BE THE SMALLEST
WE ARE THE MIGHTIEST LITTLE
CITY IN THE BAY AREA HAPPY
TO DO OUR PART IN BUILDING
AND EXPANDING THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OPTIONS TO BAY AREA
RESIDENTS AND OUR GOAL HERE
IS TO ENSURE THAT -- AS THE
CENTER NOTED HEALTH AND SOCIAL
BENEFITS COME ALONG WITHOUT
THE PACKAGE FOR SENIORS AND WE
BUILD HOUSING FOR TRANSITION
AGE FOSTER HOMES USED AS WE
GO I'M AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS
BILL WE ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU THANK YOU THERE
ARE NO OPPOSITION WITNESSES SO
LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINES TO
SEE IF THERE ARE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISH TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL TO THE OPERATOR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINES AND FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
WHETHER YOU SUPPORTER OPPOSE
THANK YOU HERE IN OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION THE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO FOR SB FIVE
NINETY ONE AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE OF NINETY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN AT IT AFTER TO
GET AFTERNOON SHERRIN MEMBERS
LOSE MONDAY LET CALIFORNIA
BE HERE IN OUR SPORT THANK
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF SEVENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YES CHAIR PERSON
CHIU AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MEETING POLITICAL
LOOK EXPRESSING GRATITUDE
TO SENATOR BACKER COMMITTEE
STAFF AND SUPPORTING THE
FOLLOWING GROUPS THIS CITY OF
BERKLEY THE CITY OF HALF MOON
BAY THE CITY OF OAKLAND THE
CITY OF PALO ALTO C.
H.
HOUSING NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND THE PENALTY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU AND ACCESSIBLE TO
LINE UP NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE
CRESCENTA VERDE ON BEHALF OF A.
R.
P.
IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF A SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON
MEMBERS RECOMMEND
CONTRIBUTING LEADING H.
CALIFORNIA I JUST WANTED
TO NOTED THAT ARTIFICIALLY
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION AS
A RESULT OF THE SENATOR'S
COMMITMENT TO TAKE ON THE
AMENDMENT -- YOU MENTIONED
AND JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE HIS
AND THE COMMITTEE'S WORK
ON THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ONLY JUST FOR STATE TO THE
SENATOR JUST APPRECIATE YOUR
CREATIVITY INNOVATION I THINK
WE'RE ALL TRYING TO THINK OF
DIFFERENT APPROACHES TO HOUSING
PARTICULARLY WITH OUR GROWING
SENIOR POPULATION AND I THINK
THE IDEA OF INTERGENERATIONAL
HOUSING AGAIN IT'S A IT'S
A VERY NOVEL ONE BUT ONE I
THINK MANY OF US APPRECIATE SO
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT AND ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH LEADING H.
AND ENSURING THAT OUR STATE
SENIOR SET ASIDE NUMBERS
UPRIVER ARE PRESERVED AT WITH
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORKS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST
WANTED TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD --
AND YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ESPECIALLY AS A FRESHMAN COMING
INTO DIVE RIGHT IN AND TACKLE
IT IS IMPORTANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THAT I ALSO WANT TO CONFIRM
AND REVEAL IS A SMALL BUT
MIGHTY CITY AND DOING THEIR
PART IN BUILDING HOUSING AND
APPRECIATE -- COUNCILMEMBER
POWDERS -- TECHNICAL EXPERTISE
IN THE BILL AND LEADERSHIP IN
THE SPACE THE BERRIES WELL AND
WOULD JUST LOVE TO BE ADDED
ON AS A CO AUTHOR TO THE BILL
AND BUT HAPPY TO BE MOVED TO
BELFAST IN THE MIDDLE RIGHT
THIS PROMOTION IS OUR SECOND AS
A SECOND OTHER COMMENTS SINAN
CENTER ANY FINAL COMMENTS THANK
YOU APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE MADAM SECRETARY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY CHU Q.
I SEE ARE CHAU HI THEY ARE TO
AYE GABRIEL GABRIEL I KALRA
KILEY KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE QUICKSILVER
AYE QUICK SILVA AYE WICKES
WICKES AT YOUR BILLS ARE
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER AND
WITH THAT WHEN WE GO THROUGH
THE AGENDA ONE MORE TIME
TO ALLOW MEMBERS TO ADD ON
MADAM SECRETARY YOU WANNA START
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR YES
-- TO BILLS ON CONSENT S.
B.
FOUR THIRTY TWO SB FIVE
EIGHTY ONE VOTE IS -- I
GUESS WE DON'T NEED IT KALRA
MAIENSCHEIN IN CHINA I HAD
SIX MONTHS AGO TO FOLLOW
ONE FILE ITEM ONE SB THREE
NINETY ONE MIN GABRIEL
GABRIEL I KALRA MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE WICKS
THAT'S SIX SIX ICE RAGE
-- AT THIS TIME I THINK OF
THE MEMBERS HERE ALL OF YOU
HAVE ADDED ON TO YOURS BILLS
WILL WAIT FOR SOMEONE NUMBER
CURRENTLY KNOWS CHAIRING
OF THE STORM YES WE NEED TO
I'M SORRY SB THREE NINETY
TWO KALRA KILEY MANGER MAIN
TRANSIT -- AND THEN SIX YEP
FROM
WHAT
THE WHOLE THERE'S NO REASON
THANK YOU FOR --
HE'S I DON'T KNOW
ALL OF YEAH
AT THE
YEAH
OKAY YEAH
WE HAVE
YEAH
WE GOT A LITTLE BIT WIDER
OKAY
YEAH --
OKAY YEAH YEAH YEAH BASICALLY
ARE YOU YEAH
YEAH YEAH -- YOU DO
YEAH
ALL RIGHT YOU
WILL I THINK THERE
RIGHT
MISTER CAR CANNELLA GO THROUGH
THE AGENDA STARTING WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEMS
THREE SB FOUR THIRTY TWO Y.
CASKEY FALLEN FOR SB FIVE
EIGHTY ONE ACTIONS KALRA KALRA
GOING BACK TO FILE -- FILE
AND ONE SB THREE NINETY ONE
MAN KALRA SB FIVE TO SB THREE
NINETY TWO ARCHULETA KALRA
ALL RIGHT FILE IN FIVE SB
FIVE NINETY ONE BAKER KALRA
OKAY CALL RIGHT AUGUST THAT
CONCLUDES OUR MEETING FOR TODAY